yeah welcome efore has been played and
let's play the lagoons defense on a lot
on or some other pronunciation I tried
this before some time ago and I got this
I didn't get e5 ok let's let's try to
transpose back and do our bills now I
can even go to a Sicilian ok let's do
this a cool transposition mmm and we got
the light off by r1 if or Knight f6 ok
the g3 line young then it's quite this
is quite a good line for wine it's one
of those some more strategically
inclined lines against them against the
night off yeah I hope this this is ok
just am developing a ch3 ng form is 11
plan that white can go for I'm suspect
that be 5s normal be 5a for something
like this maybe I can also go b6 Bishop
e7 some line like this ok let's play the
five I really don't know the theoretical
um state of of this ok so maybe he
intends to exchange Bishop before night
so I'll I cover f6 that I can recapture
if you take
of course black has got this um typical
weakness on d5 witches however
notoriously difficult to exploit it's
just rappin fianchetto after taking on
d5 he would would have taken on d5 with
the Queen attacking attacking the rook
so he am really took on his seven which
was so at least stuff for me slightly
slightly surprising okay I want to get
rid of this son this pin surprising
because this heaven Bishop didn't really
look like a great piece okay what he's
got done it's got two bishops not any
not anymore so just take here and now we
are starting to get done some pretty
standard Sicilian position where black
is just very comfortable the the pawn on
d6 is not really an issue so difficult
to see how white should them get any
substantial play against the porn I mean
this is a typical myth of the Sicilian
in some way that the deep one would be a
weakness actually it almost never gets
lost really but sometimes the the g five
squares is something else this is really
really an issue and quite a number of
games but the porn Randy Islam is the
problem
so still how do I continue I intend a
five and before on b3 I have still fc5
and it would really weaken White's
structure maybe it was it wasn't such a
great idea anyway now that I think think
of this ok but it was my idea to push
the pawn gather look at some a bit
vulnerable on the square can play b3m
and turn now yeah exactly threatening to
take on c5 yeah still ever play before
let's just think about this is this so
bad this transformation ok Emma's
Plymouth just spending too much time
here look to c 8 was a very decent
alternative the issue is he cannot go 95
here simply because the rook is hanging
on d 8 and let's take and the Queen on
c5 can be a good good piece and here
just before his hanging at the end so he
cannot go to d5 and where does the night
go
it only has he to basically or some
off-site play safe or be one when II to
isn't six exactly great also it and now
I can just take if right so it's a
central pawn if you text my queen now I
can go Queen f6 attacking f2 why this
isn't easy to defend even okay he wants
to play 93 let's go here attack f21 our
93 @ XE to it's got really bad piece
coordination yeah this is very M likes
harmony white sign position let's go
here and tending Knight f3 it goes 95 I
can play f6 I think well this this this
looks very very promising hard to
believe that I don't win material now
rook hangs and denied g5 coming Queen h3
made steady and intimated
here was it was one of those cases where
two looks again the Queen wasn't great
just because of concrete considerations
here yeah and the problem is what what
is he doing instead of this you can
retreat the night to a to end time and
let's take on before 9a to something
like this but this um as a problem also
see porn but this is not working really
simply because he doesn't have 95 the
night doesn't have a square and this is
really disastrous like winning the porn
and at the end having this very active
position this doesn't seem defensible a
95 was maybe even better but heads it's
both winning only be three is also
hanging so it doesn't she doesn't really
have a booth yeah thanks thanks for
watching this I think a pretty pretty a
good game I think what what's really
weird is that she took on his heaven
here but night XD fibers of course a
threat yes still I'd rather take we
should have 60 or something yeah okay
thanks for watching